jean-luc à l olympia mois avant jean luc
lahaye au tribunal
enfin les choses plus intimes qua non
mais c'est vachement bien moi j'ai vu
tout le dvd et c'est vrai qu'il y avait
quelque chose ce soir à l'olympia
sérieusement j'avais le trac
ouais mais l'avocat était confiant il
m'a dit je le sens bien on va péter non
coupable non mais c'est vrai il s'est
passé un truc ce soir un an
vous voulez parler de procédures non non
non c'est super émouvant parce que
j'avais pas fais l'olympia en effet
depuis 17 ans et voir cette grande salle
à blanc
c'est lui que j'aurais dû épouser puis
finalement la vie oui c'est ça hein
c'est dommage
non qu'il est sur le contre régulariser
les papiers vous ne vous aimez jean luc
lahaye d'eau est coupée au montage
bonjour sourire au milieu au revoir non
ne dis pas ça parce que je vous en veux
mais c'est pas vrai moi je vous adore
j'évite toute nue dans le film de diane
kurys est très beau ça c'est vrai à la
presse que oui pourquoi pas
l'endroit où le supporter très bien non
et vous vous aimez jean luc lahaye non
moi je suis plutôt jeff buckley